marie-france de près bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
tweets dire de stella maurice ma
compagne de julian assange
je pense qu'on réagit avec énormément
d'angoise parce que ça fait quand même
très très longtemps que l'on se bat pour
la libération de julian assange et la
maintenance cette menace elle est
vraiment extrême parce que ont réagi vos
tweets en se disant que la semaine
dernière il ya à peine une semaine
on nous a dit qu'il y avait trois
détenus qui étaient testés positifs dans
cette aile et maintenant on est passé à
49 nu et 15 membres du personnel donc
c'est extrêmement angoissant en une
semaine on est passé de 1,1 et demi pour
cent à 25% de deux personnes infectées
donc en plus on sait que rien n'a changé
à une maladie chronique des poumons et
donc qu'il est particulièrement fragile
de ce côté là donc et c'est très
angoissant
qu'est ce que vous demandez vous alors
moi enfin je vais dire personnellement
parce que je peux pas me prononcer de
plus de personnes
je pense qu'il faut absolument demander
une libération conditionnelle
et il faut est-ce qu'on l'obtiendra
il a déjà été demandée à la première
période à la première période de
confinement être que vides
le 25 mars les avocats de julian assange
ont demandé sa libération
pour cause de cogiter pour cette maladie
longs pulmonaire et elle a été refusée a
rejeté d'un de la main par un et sa
barre à terre qui a dit que vous pouvez
faire confiance à eau à la direction des
prisons pour gérer cette épidémie on
voit que on peut pas faire confiance et
donc je pense qu'il faudrait redemander
cette libération
si elle refusait c'est une preuve de
plus que on ne veut pas s'occuper d'une
façon honnête du cas de julian assange
et qu'on peut le laisser mourir en
prison et que peut-être ça arrangerait
pas mal de personnes je pense que le cas
de julian assange et il ya beaucoup de
prisonniers qui sont dans ce cas on a
demandé il ya des pays qui ont libéré
des prisonniers pour cause covit des
milliers de prisonniers en iran
en turquie il ya eu très peu de
libération en angleterre mais je pense
que julian assange c'est un cas vraiment
très très emblématique et il ya vraiment
un déni vis-à-vis de toutes les
procédures toutes les irrégularités qui
ont été commises dans sa détention dans
les procédures et c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement important si j'ai
une minute je voudrais attirer
l'attention sur le fait que justement
aujourd'hui au parlement européen
on est en train de voter j'ai pas le
résultat du vote ça devait être en vue
d' une heure et quatorze heures un
amendement à un rapport d'une commission
sur la restriction sur le respect pardon
des droits fondamentaux dans l'union
européenne
pendant les années 2018 et 2019 et la
rapporteuse de cette commission
claire délit une députée européenne
irlandaise indépendante a ajouté a fait
a ajouté le cadet julian assange est
bien des députés européens se sont
groupés pour demander qu'on supprime cet
amendement est donc le vote devait avoir
lieu aujourd'hui
pourquoi demander de supprimer à la mode
mandement par rapport à julian assange
pour le respect des droits fondamentaux
de 2018 2019 alors que deux julien
assange ricard était en 2019 en avril
2019 il a été immédiatement placé dans
la prison de belmarsh en isolement
un mois après son arrestation en avril
2010 9 en mai 2019
nick mercer a fait un rapport qui accuse
et qui montre que cet homme et est
harcelé et mis en isolement et qu'il a
subi de la torture les le royaume uni
n'a pas tenu compte de ça il n'a pas
tenu compte d'appel de centaines de
médecins qui attire aussi l'attention
sur le fait qu'il est torturé c'est
vraiment de la torture qui se passe en
union européenne
on est si rapide pour là pour critiquer
la torture quand elle se passe ailleurs
en bretagne ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne daniel brèque site
mais simplement
est oui non je suis d'accord mais alors
ne parlons pas d'union européenne
parlons de l'europe
parlons de cet occident qui veut se
montrer donneurs de leçons par rapport
au respect des droits de l'homme
ici on est dans un cas flagrant où il
n'y a pas de respect des droits de
l'homme et au parlement européen
on ne veut pas notifié ce non respect
des droits de l'homme
bon il ya des ipomées européens qui
donnent pas le pas et pour revenir sur
ce twitt de stella mûri sa compagne de
julian assange justement vous parlez de
la diplomatie mondiale est ce que vous
attendez des réactions de la part de la
communauté internationale après ce tweet
d' alerte sur la santé de 2009
alors on attendait des résultats sur
j'espère qu'il y aura des réactions de
la communauté européenne mais delà de la
communauté internationale mais j'espère
que ce sera on paiera encore une fois
que la communauté internationale est
beaucoup plus que ceux qui se présentent
d'habitude comme la communauté
internationale et les états unis a en
gros et l'europe
il ya certainement des réactions dans
beaucoup de pays mais est ce qu'on va le
savoir est ce qu'on va savoir qui ya ses
réactions
est-ce que mais chez nous est ce qu'il y
aura vraiment des réactions moi j'ai
très peur on voit réellement depuis le
début que l'on veut nier qu'il y a un
problème avec julian assange
pourquoi pas parce que justement julian
assange il est la personne qui est je
vais dire le symbole de la démocratie le
symbole de pourquoi le symbole de la
démocratie parce qu'il veut que l'on
donne de l'information aux citoyens pour
qu'ils puissent juger eux-mêmes et
intervenir eux-mêmes dans dans la
politique et ça fait quelque chose qui
est très dangereux je dirais pour ceux
qui sont qui sont en place donc est ce
qu'on aura une réaction de la communauté
internationale
je l'espère bien mais s'il n'y en a pas
c'est c'est une honte pour eux et après
est ce qu'ils peuvent encore se
prétendre des démocrates s'ils laissent
faire d s'il est pratiqué la torture
dans leur prison s'il laisse se produire
des irrégularités et s'il laisse
renfermé pour le concert et pour faire
peur aux autres journalistes
merci merci marie france de près d'avoir
répondu à des questions je rappelle que
vous êtes membre du comité frias and
belgium